Wow, that really helped me. Let's
first introduce everyone. If you
think it's no good, come early. I'm
used to it, so I don't care. Hey, everyone,
wake up. It's Kaoru, the new candidate for help.
Thank you, Brian, and Alban Carlos.
Hey, wake up.
What's the smell of running?  I don't know about
that, but I
have a potion that removes stubborn oil stains.It's so
white and fluffy that it's dazzling.I've
never had such delicious food even at my parents' house.I
have a potion that has a designated place to put it.  I have
n't moved it.There are notes scattered on the floor.I haven't
touched any chemicals or experimental materials.The
scent is a deodorant made from a mixture of tea and plant extracts.This
is how the maids smelled.  A new
life
has begun as